lava started gushing out of mount
eurogongo
on saturday night the volcano is on the
edge of goma
a city of about two million people
the river of molten rock stopped on the
outskirts of the city
but not before it destroyed dozens of
homes some of them with people trapped
inside
i have lost four people including my
sister-in-law burned here in the house
for me what happened here is almost
normal as this is the first time
to see this in my life the last eruption
nearly 20 years ago
did even more damage still this time
some people
lost everything they own
we watched the whole neighborhood go up
in smoke the fire came right down to
here
even now we can still see lava
we climbed the volcano four years ago
wildlife rangers take tourists on trips
to the summit
in the crater at the top you can see the
lava lake glowing and feel its heat
it's always simmering and every so often
it erupts the foot of an active volcano
is not a very safe place for a city but
people living here
don't have anywhere else to go the
government's promise to help
but people here don't expect much from
the authorities
they failed to give any warning in spite
of volcanologists detecting seismic
movements earlier this month
how can it be that a volcano can erupt
when the population is still in the city
they should have given us advanced
notice to vacate
can you believe the houses are burning
when the population is still here
we have lost all our documents all our
education certificates and all because
we did not prepare
thousands of people left the city mostly
on foot when the eruption began
many are still scared to go home since
the eruption there have been repeated
tremors
and people worry that'll disturb the
volcano and the lava will start flowing
again
malcolm webb al jazeera